we love an ally Daniel Radcliffe is once
again sharing his support for the queer
community and explaining why he chose to
speak out against Harry Potter author JK
Rowling's views on the transgender
Community but first some context back in
June 2020 after JK shared her
transphobic beliefs with her millions of
fans Daniel penned an open letter for
the Trevor Project which began by saying
I realize that certain press Outlets
will probably want to paint this as
infighting between JK Rowling and myself
but that is really not what this is
about nor is it what's important right
now the letter continued transgender
women are women any statement to the
contrary erases the identity and dignity
of transgender people and Daniel added
this for all the fans of the Harry
Potter franchise to all the people who
now feel that their experience of the
books has been tarnished or diminished I
am deeply sorry for the pain these
comments have caused you I really hope
that you don't entirely lose what was
valuable in these stories to you if you
haven't read Daniel's letter you should
do it now and this week in a new
interview with Indy wire Daniel
explained why he felt the need to speak
out against the woman who helped his
early career saying the reason I felt
very very much as though I needed to say
something when I did was because
particularly since finishing Potter I've
met so many queer and trans kids and
young people who had a huge amount of
identification with Potter on that
Daniel continued and so seeing them hurt
on that day I was like I wanted them to
know that not everybody in the franchise
felt that way and that was really
important Daniel continued it was really
important as I've worked with the Trevor
Project for more than 10 years and so I
don't think I would have been able to
look myself in the mirror had I not said
anything but it's not my to guess what's
going on in someone else's head now
Daniel isn't the only Harry Potter star
to speak out about Rowling's beliefs Tom
Felton who portrayed Draco Malfoy in the
franchise recently told the independent
last month I'm pro-choice Pro discussion
pro-human rights across the board and
prologue and anything that is not those
things I don't really have much time for
and we don't have time for that either
thanks Daniel and Tom keep spreading the
love
foreign hey thanks for watching ET
Canada if you want more queer
entertainment news and exclusive
interviews be sure to subscribe and
check out these videos